[Music]  the empress' dead so what happens now  we were tallied commander the Empire  will assault the very foundation of the  rebels pathetic belief in themselves  tell me I mean what is the source of  their belief help correct this  messengers presence is a great honor one  I choose to share with my daughter  Adnan's versa operation cinder is  speaking at once resistance rebellion  defiance these are concepts that cannot  be allowed to persist you have a one of  many tools by which these ideas shall be  burned with my messenger he you to your  tire operation center is the last  command of our emperor and the first  step in securing our future Inferno is  crucial to its success  what's our charges you are not verified  that information then wait for now  hear our next assignments they are  unusual that these are unusual times  go commando  you do best  [Music]